[Musique]
et alors et alors moi non plus je sais
pas nager
je vais pas chez le monde depuis
quelques temps vous pouvez vous laisser
aller à tous vos fantasmes avec le
téléphone rose
osez le sexe par téléphone 200 francs la
minute à nos sos désir harriman biquet
elle fait ce désir et tu arrives à la
plus coquine à plus sensuelle de toutes
les réponses 2 on peut dire tu es bien
tomber toi ils veulent bata plaisir quel
type de femme
grande blonde est plutôt chargé vous
pouvez compter à 1115 une tige
correspond à des comptages tu peux pas
savoir
amat 72 96 60 96 les cheveux couleur
soleil d'or on touche à mourir tu vois
quoi une belle bouche non sigean j'ai
une belle bouche sûr que j'ai une belle
bouche c'est ce que je suis en train de
faire tout de suite c'est parce que
j'aimerais le faire bosser mais vous non
pas tu vois pas je vois pas en train de
manger ton petit corps vous tombe tard
on le sent bien chouette a eu beau mon
petit cousin vrai petit pour les bretons
étaient calmes
vraiment dis-moi indiqué qu'au stade de
la conversation là on en a mis ça t'en
prends tu veux poursuivre on arrête
quand tu veux je préfère vous appelez le
mois prochain mais ça coûte en cas de
bages tendresse oui d'accord c'est un
peu cher mais alors qu'ils avertissent
[Musique]
une chaussette du tout comme son mari
public le mien c'est normal j'utilise le
savon du cac le savon doux garde les
parents qui vous savez depuis peu et fr3
est devenue la chaîne de la culture
aussi nous avons le plaisir de vous
présenter à partir d'aujourd'hui une
nouvelle émission intitulée un acteur
ligue en hauteur aujourd'hui joseph
bouillon lit proust
isabelle tourna la tête
il souffre est abominablement la mer
était démontée
c'était comme si on y ont pensé par
écrit voilà je suis avec le professeur
dit var à bord d'un engin très très très
spacieux femme est contente de mon jeu
de boules un professeur de quoi
s'agit-il
il s'agit de pet au numéro deux et
numéro deux une navette une navette une
navette qui marche comment un mec qui
marchent à casser espèces de râles
hausse découle évidemment à gaz butane à
gaz propane comme nous allons partir
dans l'espace professeur ses formes y
ont voient pas sur le coeur mais nous
sommes déjà dans l'espace nécessaire
mais je vous rassure mais regardez mais
regardez enfin j'aperçois j'aperçois le
patois les bergénias laignel oui je
pense qu'un seul ours polaires
avant de décoller il faut que j'aille
chercher les professions bush
informez vous n'oubliez pas vous pouvez
me ramener s'il vous plaît un sandwich
au jambon et canettes de bière merci
professeur [ __ ] j'étais persuadé que
dans l'espace
aujourd'hui
économique et social l'été 1985
aura-t-il était propice pour tous les
hôteliers qui vivent sur le littoral
excusez moi petit problème
ni que
à
économique et social l'été 1985
or at il été bénéfique pour tous les
hôteliers de du littoral provence alpes
côte d'azur
c'est une question qu'on est appelé à se
poser à se poser
dynastique d inique
dans le cas où pendriez en cours de
route cette grande saga historique voici
un résumé des épisodes précédents
l'histoire se déroule dans une
principauté imaginaire situé à 30
kilomètres de nice à crapaud quel joli
crappy bonjour le trap au prince quel
joli prince je vais lui faire un bisou
bonjour le prince m'a bienfaitrice en
m'embrassant tu a rompu le sort qu'on
avait jeté sur mon berceau qu'elle était
beauté moi je fais partie la dynastie
des ebooks book
quel est ton prénom nadine maginot
j'ai bien connu ta mère ça s'appelle un
coup de foudre
le prince lui l'ue va immédiatement
demandé la main de la belle nadine
ebooks à son père le roi devra partir
pour jérusalem
chez mokhtar tu devras me ramener 2 kg
de boudin blanc dès que le prince lui
par pour jérusalem ne dîne se fait
enlever par le ps 14 et son fidèle akbar
clou ils l'entraînent dans son harem aux
confins du désert
[Musique]
kaka
en fait je
les
[Musique]
jamila
pendant ce temps lui arrive à jérusalem
et rencontres kassim germes ou d'un
chien un boudin blanc
[Musique]
vers 2 h à la meinau sous les voûtes
bien que pendant ce temps le pesq à tort
commence à saturer de la belle n'a dit
ni mook et essaye de la revendre le
temps chambre il la gandoura et brûlé je
n'ai play les babouches de cette mon
coeur je peux plus tendus l'ouvrier
france et blanc de préférence je peux
plus je peux plus je fais quelque chose
tout de suite à l'eau les variations
très bien passé - les petites annonces
le prince lui oublie nadine ebooks dans
les bras des chats écrasés
tu sais toi la phrase qui tirait bien
celle de bachelard si je trouve plus con
que moi je veux tu pourras c'est tout
c'est vrai parce que ma mère le disait
un plus pour que toi on meurt je peux
pas je peux pas vivre avec toi je peux
plus rester avec à ba1 alors je me casse
je retourne chez kassim avec lui au
moins je pouvais discuter avec lui au
moins je pouvais philosopher eh ben ça
tombe bien parce que je commençais moi
aussi en avoir marre claque
aïcha écrasé lorient serait ennaji bon
d'accord ça volait pas haut meaux -
l'embrasser elle pensait à la décoration
de la maison celle là va chez ta mère
tiens elle n'aura pas eu le temps
d'aller chez sa mère à moins qu a quand
même des noms prédestinés elle tient à
les chats écrasés à écraser voilà c'est
tout d'où l'expression populaire mais
pas dans la suite qu'elle fit un pierre
berger allemand est à son tour mordu
pour nadine berger quel joli berger
allemand
je vais faire un petit bonjour les
bergers allemands
bonjour et belle enfant tu sais comme
invité exactement les garder ta maison
est pâtent hamelin ouamane le décor est
planté
les personnages aussi où vous êtes
maintenant fin prêt à suivre la suite de
cette grande saga la dynastie des ebooks
ne ratez pas dès samedi prochain
votre grand feuilleton quelques
dromadaires la dynastie des ebooks
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes tous là pour rigoler édité en
france ont failli beaucoup d'impôts mais
qu'est ce qu'on rigole
vous allez l'avoir la dernière alors
justement là voilà qu'arrive l'histoire
de deux chinois de chinois qui marchent
dans une rue
et alors nos deux chinois arrivent en
sens inverse
n'est ce pas et arrive au moment où ils
vont se croiser et à ce moment précis où
ils se croisent des choix regard de
l'autre et lui dit salut maurice
salut police
salut maori
mathieu regarde à la mûre
[Musique]
doucement
les étoiles eux
[Musique]
paris
on
[Musique]
je
oh
les amis célèbres la véritable histoire
d'amour
césar et marc antoine diot bas on
applique la marque
j'ai appris que des revues césar
aujourd'hui je t'interdis leur joie j'ai
le droit d'accueillir ces armes ont pas
laissé le clairement dit je te perdu de
revoir ce genre toi mais jaloux et la
chaîne
[Musique]
c'est ça
mons usa marc antoine
or pas du tout mesdames messieurs
bonsoir voici l'émission humoristique
d'affaires 3 et wii avec une première
histoire l'histoire de deux chinois qui
se rend compte alors la seule émission
qui dérègle même votre téléviseur
membres dont la monnaie n'est pas de
mener de la monuc cité mythique
depeche mode et parfois avec
[Musique]
voilà notre édition
nous allons nous quitter mais nous
allons nous retrouver la semaine
prochaine samedi prochain ne manquez pas
notre nouvelle émission tous les samedis
sur fr3 et je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée
[Musique]